wird diese gas umlage zu mehr armut
führen in deutschland das fragen sie
sich das fragen wir uns alle in jedem
fall berichten unsere reporter schon
jetzt kommen immer mehr menschen zu den
tafeln zur essensausgabe auch wegen der
explodierenden energiepreise ist ja klar
deutschland im teuer schock die kosten
für gas und strom explodieren und auch
ansonsten steigen die preise im
supermarkt die folge bei den tafeln
bilden sich lange schlangen eine umfrage
unter 600 tafeln im juni ergab die zahl
der hilfsbedürftigen dort hat sich seit
anfang des jahres um mehr als die hälfte
erhöht auf rund zwei millionen kunden
früher standen hier die wirklich armen
für lebensmittel schlange doch nun wird
das klientel zunehmend bürgerlich denn
die inflation bringt auch
normalverdiener an ihre grenzen
entlastung ist nicht in sicht im
gegenteil der preis haben wir bei den
energiekosten ist bei den verbrauchern
ja noch gar nicht angekommen gas umlage
sowie wegfall des tank rabatt und des
neuen euro tickets dürften die inflation
im herbst noch einmal ansteigen lassen
fürchten wirtschaftswissenschaftler auf
bis zu zehn prozent kein wunder dass die
tafeln an ihre grenzen kommen die
lebensmittel spenden reichen nicht mehr
aus auch an helfern fehlt es vielerorts
schon ein drittel der tafeln in
deutschland hat deshalb einen
aufnahmestopp für neue kunden verhängt
mehr armut durch die neue gas umlage
mehr armut auch ja vor allen dingen
natürlich seit monaten durch die
explodierenden energiepreise in
deutschland unser reporter michael
engelberg der ist jetzt bei der tafel
sagt theodor in köln die ja voll ist
ja guten morgen kam aus köln wie du es
schon gesagt dass wir zeigen dass man
eben hier haben schon die ersten kunden
ihre wagen hingestellt das kuriose ist
dass die ausgabestelle heute erst um 15
uhr öffnet das ganze ist tatsächlich an
die katholische kirchengemeinde hier
sagt theodor angebunden und in den
räumen da unten die sich gegen mittag
füllen werden werden dann die kunden mit
lebensmitteln versorgt neben mir steht
der leiter norbert theis herz es ist
noch früh am morgen ihr tag beginnt
trotzdem früh wie viele leute können sie
hier heute mit lebensmitteln versorgen
und wer kommt zu ihnen als kunde also
wir können ungefähr zirka 180 bis 200
kunden versorgung mit lebensmitteln
kommen tut alles von senioren von
familien mit vielen kindern
flüchtlinge kommen deswegen durch die
bank alle jetzt haben sie mir im
vorgespräch schon gesagt durch corona
hat sich vieles entzerrt sie könnten
aber auch noch weitere leute aufnehmen
wie handhaben sie das werk kommt zu
ihnen ich brauche heute hilfe wie
funktioniert das dann also wer heute
heute bei einer neuanmeldung kommt der
bekommt auf jeden fall einmal
lebensmitteln und beim nächsten mal muss
er seine bedürftigkeit nachprüfen dann
wollen wir einmal den hartz4 bescheid
sehen oder die sozialen den ja die
sozialhilfe bescheinigung oder
rentenbescheid hin wollen wir einmal
sehen dass wir haben so eine grenze wo
wir sagen so wer darüber ist der ist
nicht bedürftig es gibt so viele leute
die haben so wenig da sind sie leider
drüber und selbst da haben wir uns noch
ein spielraum gesetz von 100 euro und
können okay ist egal nehmen wir trotzdem
auf jetzt ist die gasanlage gestern
beschlossen worden man geht davon aus
dass die energiekosten zum ende des
jahres sehr und sehr mehr und mehr
steigen rechnen sie denn auch bei ihren
kunden dass es gegen ende des jahres
noch weiter anwächst
ich gehe davon aus dass wird nicht
ausbleiben das andere problem ist man
hat nicht so viel kapazität und wenn
jetzt sagen wir mal noch 100 leute
jahrhundert kunden hinkommen davon
können wir nur 30 aufnehmen das liegt
daran weil sie nicht genügend
lebensmittel haben oder dann können sie
die hier nicht verarbeiten mich
verarbeiten könnte zeit das ist ja man
muss sagen und pro kunde zwei minuten
das heißt wir haben zwei minuten zeit
zum verarbeiten von alles dafür
anzunehmen tasche packen tasche
rausgehen zwei minuten das heißt aber
auch wir müssen dementsprechend wieder
lebensmittel haben das heißt wir müssen
noch mehr helfer haben das ist eine
blase die immer mehr wächst und man muss
sollte zweiter haben es dreht sich so
ein bisschen wie im karussell aber sie
sind hier der leiter wie sie kommen mit
den leuten ins gespräch
was bringt ihnen die kunden hier in die
kirchengemeinde sind die geschichten
ähnlich sprechen die leute darüber
schämen die sich eventuell wo man sich
immerhin wo man sich natürlich nicht
verstehen muss wenn man hilfe braucht
wie kommen sie mit den leuten ins
gespräch die kopfhörer gut wie komme ich
mit den leuten ins gespräch das ist ja
auch schwer zu sagen da ist habe ich mir
nie darum mache ich mir nie gedanken
darüber also die neue neue kunden die
schämen sich am anfang ja da haben wir
aber am meisten dass sie müssen sich
nicht schämen wir verlangen geld da für
sie kriegen also nicht geschenkt
im grunde genommen ist es fast geschenkt
aber sie müssen bezahlen dafür und wenn
man einmal dabei ist und sie kriegen mit
das wird wie wir behandelt wie ganz
normale menschen das sind kunden
deswegen sagen wir auch kunden dass
unsere kunden und kein bittsteller kein
gar nichts sondern reine kunden und die
werden auch so behandelt aber wir müssen
natürlich auch so behandelt werden
deswegen ich glaube nach dem zweiten
dritten mal hat sich das alles dann
gelegt hat ist das normal hier werden
kunden behandelt die ganz normale
menschen das muss auch so sein die
tafeln werden
in diesem jahr knapp 1,7 1,8 millionen
leuten zur seite stehen und helfen mit
diesen ersten eindrücken hier aus köln
zurück nach berlin
[Musik]